foreign
the other thing that there is shame to
be talked about is on federal
prosecutors I have been talking on my
own channel for
years now about consequence for Donald
Trump in the wake of the attempted
overthrow of the United States
government the Insurrection the failed
coup attempt
by way of overturning a free and fair
election
they could prosecute that
they could have prosecuted obstruction
of justice the multiple cases of
obstruction of justice outlined in the
Mueller report they didn't and in this
case they could have prosecuted the hush
money payments made to Stormy Daniels
but instead prosecutors and I'm going to
read a little bit from this instead
prosecutors thought oh well this this
will seem small in comparison to all of
the insane treason
and other crimes of Donald Trump we're
just not going to bring this and this is
a problem
Justice should be met Justice should be
served no matter if you think it's a
small matter and something along
something else will come along
get past the buck to someone else when
you have a prosecutable crime before you
reading from the CNN article Federal
prosecutors discussed charging Trump and
Stormy Daniels case when he left office
book says days before then president
Donald Trump left the White House
Federal prosecutors in New York
discussed whether to potentially charge
Trump with campaign Finance crimes once
he was out of office according to a new
book from senior CNN legal analyst Ellie
honig prosecutors from the southern
district of New York developed
significant evidence against Trump when
they charged his former attorney Michael
Cohen in 2018 over a hush money scheme
paying two women claiming affairs with
Trump including adult film star Stormy
Daniels honig writes but prosecutors did
not consider charging Trump at the time
because of long-standing justice
department guidance that a sitting
president cannot be indicted I hope you
caught that I hope you caught that one
line in there that they
developed significant evidence against
Trump when they charged his former
attorney and then eventually had a
conviction for Michael Cohen
they had evidence
and they chose not to prosecute
this is this is a failure of the United
States justice department this is a
failure of Justice in general it should
be dispassionate he committed a crime
you convict you investigate you
prosecute and you secure a conviction
I understand that the office of legal
counsel within the Department of Justice
has a long-standing memo this isn't law
this is an opinion within a division of
the Department of Justice that says you
can't charge a sitting president that is
nonsense and many experts agree
continuing with the article here with
Trump about to leave office in January
2021 however Audrey Strauss the acting
U.S attorney held multiple discussions
with a small group of prosecutors to
discuss its evidence against Trump they
decided to not seek an indictment of
trump for several reasons honig writes
including the political ramifications
and the fact that Trump's other scandals
such as efforts to overturn the 2020
presidential election and the January 6
2021 Insurrection made the campaign
Finance violation seemed somehow trivial
and outdated by comparison
what
the crime was committed was it not you
secured a conviction with someone
involved with the crime why would you
let Donald Trump off the hook
is it laziness
what is it
it's malpractice
as far as I'm concerned continuing here
quote we were well aware of the
Prudential reasons why you wouldn't
charge a president even after he was out
of office while Federal prosecutors in
New York opted not to pursue their case
against Donald Trump Manhattan district
attorney Alvin Bragg appears to be
looking into the matter again Cohen met
this month with prosecutors from his
office the first such meeting in more
than a year and the clearest sign to
date that the Manhattan district
attorney is Syrian in on the Trump
organization's involvement in the husk
money payments so look look
I have said this going back in the days
after the Insurrection that we are going
to have to rely upon journalists and
people writing books
for uh the investigatory work to be done
because Federal prosecutors they're not
up to it in my estimation
Merrick Garland has sat on his hands
under the guise of well we want to be
thorough
and slow paced in in our in in our
investigation that we want to do this
the right way and sober minded
we don't need to drag our feet until Joe
Biden isn't President anymore and then
the entire thing is scuttled
and here we have further evidence that
they just decided not to prosecute
because oh there's bigger things
Republicans right now want to talk about
a two-tier justice system in the United
States Joe Biden's not being treated the
same way as Donald Trump about the
documents
none of that is true but that's not what
two-tiered is they're both presidents
that's one tier
it's that if I committed the same crimes
as Donald Trump I'd be sitting my ass in
a prison right now but because he's rich
because he's an ex-president because he
has powerful connections he gets a pass
and federal prosecutors gave him that
pass it's all
too much
I love to know what you think let's mix
it up in the comments and uh follow me
you can subscribe to my YouTube channel
jessiedollamore or follow me on
um Twitter Instagram Tick Tock at
dollarmore I'd love to see you there
thanks a lot for joining me today